oh don't brush my name's welcome back to
outlast 2 we just found the chapel right
there right there it's [ __ ] huge main
uh [ __ ] it's dark
oh [ __ ] I made the same mistake like
it's not [ __ ] fair because I have a
[ __ ] I haven't lied in my face and
I'm looking at a game that's already
supposed to be dark funky now
alright here we go alright all the
support that I'm getting so far on this
there's has been [ __ ] awesome thank
you guys namaste domo arigato Huxley a
blemish yeah ha ha just appreciate it
it's really cool I'm really excited
batteries I hope you don't mind buddy
someone needs your cheek by the way is
Hannibal Lecter here or some [ __ ]
alright down we go
guess I gotta use the [ __ ] thing
hey someone made a bridge here oh nice
this looks nice nice and safe here I
think I live here in all the cage
ah hell no aw hell no the game reminds
me of condemned a little bit you guys
remember that game apparently that game
is banned in Germany to play some german
youtuber wrote me and said that the
police asked him about it and then they
showed a video of me [ __ ] crazy
can you imagine can you imagine if
police would knock on your door for
playing a [ __ ] video game now i can't
pick that great
I just really hope this video doesn't
get any monetize like you to be so
sensitively you say this is supposed to
be like a safe zone I don't know what
the [ __ ] is that
which got skinned yo
it's so dark Jesus oh my god look [ __ ]
how you doing buddy
it's that guy again our Lord and see
they really love dolls don't they they
really love don't check out I want to
make sure we get everything God some
objects a little pushed in front of a
door to block act and operate like this
for example I don't know I I don't read
the notes because I think most people
don't want them to but if you want a
pause you know I want to give it leave
enough room there we go
I don't know why I'm doing this if
anything I just need to pull my
fingernails
hey how about damn how about a kill
myself okay here we go what okay that
door was blocked all right it's always
funny when you don't solve puzzles with
that foot
before you found the problem if that
makes sense that might be an elevator
that might be an elevator what are you
smoking you need to start the generator
okay do I need the gas I need to go here
ah
the game is intense man
are they coming let's go I want to be
here when they arrive oh [ __ ] that
scared me give me an egg why would we
trying to lift
but this is hard I'm really cracking
here nobody go
a race tonight at first
oh my god you [ __ ] weirdo Lajoie dude
you think you'll attack me now that
answer that question all right well
let's not enter strangers homes anymore
you know now I know now I know thank you
very much
the guy doesn't like it what if we open
it slowly hey maybe I'm not immersing Oh
what the [ __ ] I'm not going to go near
that crazy all right what do we got here
don't mind me don't mind me guys is this
how you live in America by the way then
is anyone from Arizona watching this I'm
genuinely curious just like you guys
collect [ __ ] [ __ ] in there [ __ ] you
got sack of potatoes around I'm
genuinely here please sometime because
honestly this is great how fast is your
internet here
you go upstairs how does the person
hello bad bad collapse
ha ha ha shut up okay push this just
trying to find like batteries and [ __ ]
like that keeping an eye on for
batteries
like they could turn late breaking forth
okay well that was pointless great
collide with you then [ __ ] what is this
[ __ ] city man
hey Loretta
Pakistan County [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh you [ __ ]
no leave me alone man I'm outta here
close but [ __ ] little mark ever find
I've refined all right ah [ __ ] how do I
get the generator running this is bad
shit's real bad boy okay we did it
fine Mia what a great name
alright generator must be here somewhere
well well look what we found
I can find my way back to the elevator
oh [ __ ] we got it boy but what the [ __ ]
little nice - lady let's let her let's
let her do her thing okay
just got a feeling that we should not
interact with that crazy son of a [ __ ]
but Dad am so am i right not a battery
nothing we saw the [ __ ] miracle
matter here [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I'm just going to find our way back
I think another way
I'm just going to run for it I think
running for it is the way to go in this
game
this way
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] nutter [ __ ] man oh
[ __ ] you back
she's fastest [ __ ] boy right [ __ ]
exhausting but I shoot her
did I set that oh [ __ ] okay yep and then
we run here
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
I think she's pretty fast though I think
she's pretty fast and I'm pretty tired
go go go go go go go go go back we'll be
rappin hell yeah hell yeah we got that
[ __ ] got him got him
easy boy whoo God forsake you
I mean you look good you look real good
talking hell my heart is beating so fast
look at that bald son of a [ __ ] why you
got to be bald though oh I'm feeling
temple yi
that's a chapel no it's not awesome
[ __ ] sake you what you're wasting my
battery now that's what you're doing
here
they're nice sharp for the enemy all
right let's look at the video I enjoyed
the temple gate founded by Sullivan not
modern Ezekiel your knives sharp for the
enemy I mean I [ __ ] read this are you
talking about
Lacey my god damn town boy I can't go
there I don't understand why she's so
mean you know that that I had Jesus lady
she's neat yes because you just say
Jessica
there check the well in technical what
the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] but what what what
should happen great if outlet 1 now
crawling in corridor pocket
really [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh my god what's happening oh yeah we
played this in the demo oh look I don't
know I was that fat why is this type of
feeling like the standard feeling and
anti budget public building ever like I
have the same feel like walk by that
standard it is that cheap Catholic
school the way to success under credit
free [ __ ] boy [ __ ] me man
Catholic school well like where's the
way to success
it's gotta be here somewhere I'm sure of
it what the [ __ ] just happened one
Jessica's in it I [ __ ] miss the
battery why would you do this battery
[Applause]
when the money was gone and you can't go
on battery
[Music]
they're not cranking get enough fur but
are not crank that jet come on boy
I don't know where I'm going
hello I like that room corn I feel like
you could kick those doors in
[Music]
you really wanted to write for Fox they
come on just just to go with the phone
where you going you crazy [ __ ]
okay ah did you leave a budget hey give
her a bank what's the story here what
happened to Jessica how is she connected
with this place why are we you know
we're clearly Oh
oh my god oh oh oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] are we
gonna have to run now [ __ ] boy oh I'm
running boy I'm outta here boy yes yep
[ __ ] what do I go ah
jump how's everyone doing here top of
the moment of life why is everyone crazy
you can lock doors
okay that didn't work [ __ ]
Jim Lane not way off Russia here the
burg go can't fine oh [ __ ] it's bread
[ __ ] behind me go go go
boy boy you better hurry the [ __ ] up bro
fast
no not real now where you go okay go go
go go go whoo I'm getting scared by
flashbacks they same good name your
friend [ __ ] behind me
oh [ __ ] is right behind me literally Gus
yeah what do I go oh they're everywhere
step back
yeah [ __ ] Oh benches play soccer what
are you gonna do your mom thinks it
burned yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah whoa
okay okay whoo oh man
I'm so freaked out why is it so many
babies cake made pretty pass that's
disgusting
I'm not going to change you back I just
[ __ ] my pants
how you doing buddy great oh no the
phones it burns
[ __ ]
you took my spot dude fire oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
Bank Street that's okay we're fine I'm
fine I'm fine honestly I'm fine we're
all fine everyone's happy should
probably do a quick little heal a little
bit of an itch that should do the trick
thank you very much there we go he'll
never find me now push that thing just
in case just for safety and then after
that I'll promise I will clean my how do
I get out of here planted or isn't it
there oh [ __ ] that's just not fair yes
[ __ ] yeah yeah I know
oh hell no much much much much much much
better Westbourne push more again
[Music]
no no [ __ ] oh where are we
sorry I'm screaming so much I'm [ __ ]
up don't record now get out of here
not ask though come down let me get us
some nail shine okay what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me
Jesus Christ no integrity okay uh [ __ ]
where are we okay he'll do a quick he'll
check the videotape a chapel somebody's
there will know where they've taken
Linda
yeah no I got it okay this is where the
magic happens
ha ha ha ha I'm not watch I only saw her
afterwards I couldn't have wait what
oh that's how you use the bandage if you
want to if you just press f anyway
[ __ ] that's horrible
sorry I I don't mean to be insensitive
or whatever just trying to line in the
Moodle up this bill is to the game like
whatever
ah [ __ ] it's that it's called don't
[ __ ] fall whatever the [ __ ] you do
geez that cry oh my god
oh that's a pity
I'm trying to keep the battery for as
long as I can use it you know that's why
I don't always reload even though it's
clearly beating over all right nice
you've got a save I really enjoy the
game I love the style I love this
setting I'm really curious about the
story you know some more [ __ ] up shits
gonna happen those boots are [ __ ]
everywhere
it's a box I would open it
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] leave me alone
he's upstairs did they just say that
ah where do I run the boat Bitburg hi
guys
there
[ __ ] they really hate me don't think oh
[ __ ] I'm so dead oh my god I'm so
[ __ ] that Jesus Christ dude what the
[ __ ]
toilet
[Music]
[Applause]
I can jump over
[Music]
I don't know
you ain't got [ __ ] boy you ain't got
[ __ ] boy but I hate me they're horrible
oh my gosh
oh [ __ ] don't Pierce me I'm good
repeating wrong i brough I just use the
tricycle [ __ ]
I hope that's open because otherwise
that there
maybe you're just supposed to jump up
here oh my god was it that obvious
oh I'm such an idiot it didn't look open
oh my god I'm go go go [ __ ] man I'm
having a banging Jesus try some an idiot
run your ring you need to run buddy you
need to [ __ ] run mate come on go
through man I'm having a bad day moving
a really bad huh yeah
I don't have any bandages [ __ ] but it's
that vein - Jess nice we did a breast
that was cool
[ __ ] I'm so [ __ ] on edge I hope I
hope you're doing all right mate oh man
jeez guys I need Jesus after this game
Catholic now hey doing buddy just
killing nice boots chillin with my boots
schoolroom don't be afraid you're going
to heaven that's cool tonight the [ __ ]
is this guy with the main man is like a
real pimp any all right what the [ __ ]
what just happened
a my music I think so I do think so
chapels got it closed
just watch the tapes clay I mean they'll
go into heaven good before they killed
the children not you should have loved
to be what are you doing yeah what are
you doing oh there's a door here Oh God
creepy hey chicken wings I sure love
some chicken wing remember there's no
pain in heaven
God knows best draw angel excellent I
don't want to crawl under the bed and
hide I'm not a push sign right rose we
ain't no [ __ ] they after me I'm not a
person um ah [ __ ] I didn't want to fall
off
do you have no badge
great all right well we're out you're
bleeding you need to find well let the
[ __ ] I'm not the one that jumped up the
ceiling shut up are we going to castle
yet believe everywhere something to
stand on her all right we can push this
oh no I never seen it play with me
who said that oh [ __ ] she's there did
you see her I don't like her
oh my god hi guys don't tell me oh [ __ ]
we're on the other side now this is
where we were before
isn't that right and that's the leave
the guy who watch minecraft minecraft
video game
I won't say this game of actually
carrying you will be as heavy oh excuse
me I didn't know you were there
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
Christianity I didn't kill it hey I said
no hell no please please let me go to
everybody push push push push whispers
whispers whispers whispers whispers
whispers whispers whispers kept pushing
that no you're [ __ ] up my god no I
didn't know anything you jump it yeah
you got [ __ ] you got mugged [ __ ]
gotta know that crash cart once for me
but yeah I don't know what you guys want
from me but why [ __ ] yeah I'm not
here man I'm looking up doing all right
what time is it up I can't [ __ ] man this
game is stressing me the [ __ ] out are
you holding up buddy doing good product
Hey look it's nothing okay what the [ __ ]
oh we made it we [ __ ] made it
hallelujah oh oh my God give me a break
pleasure the chapel is supposed to be
sanctuary it's supposed to be well oh
god what was that
it's worth checking in either they don't
have doorknobs
wow that looks great they say getting
good vibes of this place getting great
Wyatt I have a feeling we shouldn't
really be entering here
okay well it's actually not that bad
you got a note Sullivan not let's say
him right what's his deal what it says
move backward oh sorry
can hiding me my name is Lake Tiger the
father I'm not anybody's father
I just happening
you think for the product
excuse me won't everything to hurt her
please
it saves one answer here something's
gonna happen oh [ __ ] we found it
sadly monks happen all ohh my time a
woman unburdened by any man what did it
come with either one talking very oh oh
[ __ ] it with him oh my god Sullivan I
could God hates
battery so do I the outside of woman has
this world's destruction in her womb but
valid is locked away the unborn enemy
the fiend father is escaped you will
bear for a year before dawn we have only
these few hours to find the calling me
the father and save this paradise from
here level active it is he where nothing
concerning our girlfriend huh
this is for you lose I'll make the woman
scream Oh
[Music]
the woman the wounded hoppers the
Antichrist well what I feel like we came
in a bad time oh my god Mike that's
writing me like a million times I got it
oh don't you miss all right Mary
the mind is me like I'm wearing your
network that's why I'm so confused about
the noise I was like where is it coming
from now before the birth we are the
hands of the law we cannot fail the
world dies
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh my god yeah
do they both die I guess so
holy [ __ ] I recording 1080p take it's
really good bit break with a [ __ ]
device the mines okay we got a new
objection I got a new place to go
alright maybe yeah through here road to
the - somewhere around here find a path
to the mine
[Applause]
not that again
let me go
just let me be man alright the mind No
Chris
oh boy
so [ __ ] tired of being changed at
this point
well I didn't really work
don't hurt me while I do this please
wait for me thank you
a lot of time to yield oh [ __ ]
I'm so dead run buddy it doesn't [ __ ]
run
yeah I'm climbing the water tower you
got a problem today [ __ ] I died cuz I
didn't have enough pal okay
there we go yeah yeah [ __ ] battery what
do I do now hey we're fine we're fine
everyone let's go to the mind let's go
to the math punch that is a fat cactus
where do we go now
like a hole here always look for holes
there's a lot of tricycles in this game
there must be something with the
children yes
Hey oh well stick of the devil that is
absolutely [ __ ] up don't mind me I'm
just going to get that bag that you can
crazy [ __ ] ah come on man I'm not doing
anything all right don't tell anyone I'm
here all right
sorry where else can you go
I don't know man I hear of course excuse
me do you know whether my uh oh you
[ __ ] ratted me out man
oh [ __ ]
just running through some corn I need
just yell knowledge there's some light
over here I'm not doing too well am I
all right I don't know what we're doing
here but we're here let's go in here
everyone
[ __ ] I'm so tired of being chased you
have no idea
this is cool plate alright I think I'm
gonna have to end it here alright I hope
you both enjoy this episode thank you
for all the support liebe like I really
appreciate it I'm so glad you guys are
loving this because I'm loving playing
in oh man whoo I was an intense one did
good stay awesome bro see in the next
one